breaking news now out of The Hague where
there's been a major development in the
case of a Hindu Muslims and the claims
of genocide in the past few minutes the
International Court of Justice has ruled
that Myanmar must take all possible
measures to prevent its military from
carrying out genocide they've ordered
Myanmar's government to protect all
evidence
al-jazeera's tumblr Chaudhary is
standing by for us in Cox's Bazar in
Bangladesh which is home to hundreds of
thousands of her hinder refugees but
first let's go live now to Nev Barker
who's at The Hague that Nev tell us more
about this ruling
well let me start by giving you a bit of
context at last November the Gambia
brought this case against Myanmar the
Gambia had the backing of 57 largely
Muslim countries in doing this the
country alleges that Myanmar has
breached the UN Convention on genocide
that all-important 1948 convention
signed in the wake of the second world
war not only to punish but to prevent
genocide from ever happening again that
was an earlier hearing in December
attended by the civilian leader of me
out of Myanmar and sang Suchi she wasn't
here today for this final result what
the court has been asked to do is rule
on two things to say whether or not it
has jurisdiction and it has come back
saying it does indeed have jurisdiction
meaning a genocide trial will take place
and secondly it was asked by the Gambia
to to impose something called
provisional measures which amounts to an
emergency injunction to put the brakes
on any form of genocide all violence
what we've heard from the court a short
while ago is that there are terms on
what it wants me our mark to do wants to
make sure that its military and all
irregular forces that work alongside it
stop all acts of violence including rape
the burning of villages mass murder the
prevention of access to medicine it says
also asked me our motto pervert preserve
all evidence when it comes to the
ongoing trial the future trial of
genocide and are also further terms when
it comes to the timing as well it wants
me out Mar to report back four months
from today and then every six months
going forward to show exactly what it's
doing to the international community to
prove that it is actually living up to
what the ICJ the UN's highest course is
now imposed upon it does beyond I have
to follow this ruling or is it merely
symbolic
well that's the problem the ICJ despite
the fact that it's described as the
world caught the world's highest court
this ruling is binding but it cannot be
in force that's the problem and in the
past other countries have simply ignored
them but what can be done in terms of
escalating pressure or on Myanmar as it
could in theory take things all the way
to the UN Security Council but given the
makeup of the UN Security Council with
the likes of China and Russia being
sympathetic towards Myanmar the thought
of the possibility of any serious
resolution being slapped upon Myanmar is
somewhat dwindles in that respect an
awful lot of faith and trust as opposed
is being put in Myanmar to act off its
own back and given that hang seng sue
she came here in person in December
something that she didn't have to do
does show to some extent that she
respects the jurisdiction of the court
but whether or not they will actually
act upon what the court has imposed upon
Myanmar is a different question entirely
the fact that these time frames over
four months and six months checkups have
been imposed at all
in implies that the court really wants
to see some movement from Yama's
leadership al jazeera Steve Barker
reporting live there from The Hague
let's go to Cox's Bazar in Bangladesh
where Al Jazeera stampy Acharya is right
now I know the ruling came out what
within the last 30 40 minutes or so time
here so perhaps a little bit early but
what's what's been the reaction there to
this well so far I haven't got a chance
to talk to anybody but last few days
we've been talking to many of the camp
residents the community leaders we asked
them hypothetically what if the ruling
is in favor of the RO Inga's and they
said that we've welcomed this I mean
it's it's a very much waiting for a long
time we want some sort of justice so
this would be very much welcoming news
to them as well as for Bangladesh
government and Bangladesh itself which
has been hosting over a million that
nearly a million refugees for over years
now so they would welcome this because
they had been persuading the
international community to insert
pressure on Myanmar and to acknowledge
the fact that I trusted is being
committed on the other side which is why
so many
influx took place in 2017 and onwards
even now on and off Lord of Rohan gah
start trickling down on the border
because of the atrocity still been going
on there the fortified rights and a
human rights body just a week back put
in its report about 125,000 low-hangers
an internment camp
many of them are coerced to accept this
national verification card which is
nothing more than a card that says
they're Muslim Bengalis it doesn't
verify anything else so this would be
symbolically a big gesture for the
Rohingya community here as well as for
the Bangladesh government and the nation
itself because they've been trying to
put this across to the international
community what it will do in tangible
term is the next question will it
facilitate the further a quicker
repatriation for the rowing as we don't
know I mean will it encourage many of
the nation to actually impose sanctions
on Myanmar will it empower the you and
other bodies to do something more about
this this will have to see actions can
deliver Myanmar abide by this ruling you
know so in the end it's very symbolic
it's a moral victory if nothing else
it's a psychological victory and rowing
us will be very much welcoming we'll
bring you more from the camp in coming
days al Jazeera is 10 via Chery
reporting live there from Cox's Bazar
Bangladesh and there are many thinks
indeed